all right important question though
what's the best company what was your
convenience store of choice uh okay I
started with 7-Eleven but I think I got
converted to Lawson yes okay okay I feel
like all the normal choices they start
7-Eleven and it's like okay yeah the
Fried Chicken's good like and I was
right next to the 7-Eleven as well like
I had walk out my door two minute walk
7-Eleven yeah so like I definitely still
go there for like the easy ones but if I
could make it to Lawson there's an extra
like five minute walk I always walk
there yeah distance or drive the extra
mile for the persons because it's just
so much better yeah the coffee's decent
the the food they have the sandwiches
those hot Bento things with the tattoo
things oh yeah sure good it's they don't
mess Lawson's really up the game yeah
yeah and they look they're snacks and
they're like own brand snacks yeah
they're so much better awesome branded
stuff yeah that's so good it's really
good the thing I noticed that 7-Eleven
has like one or two like good food
pieces I think yeah just that's it and
everything else is just overshadows
enough
all my homies hate family marks and
they're everywhere actually only the
real ones they run Tokyo as well you're
just in my area which was none yeah yeah
yeah I don't know it's so weird it pains
me whenever someone goes to uh Japan and
they were like I got some family my
chicken and I [__] loved it
I'm calling you out Chris because I've
got no questions converted to Lawson's I
see okay okay it only took him 10 years
he was telling me that apparently like
10 years ago like Lawson's just wasn't
that good and it was pretty bad and then
they had like a massive revamp like five
six years ago yeah we kind of root just
were like we're redoing everything yo
season two Lawson yeah [__] slap they
just like they just like up the game and
then like now like they collaborate with
like Muji which is a Japanese kind of
like kind of Ikea more minimalist yeah
yeah they just have all of like they're
really nice stuff in their stores like
it's really nice food also slaps do yeah
everything have they're so good yeah
yeah what else did you enjoy about Japan
when you were living there oh geez oh
wait I mean we did a stint in Kyoto for
like a couple weeks we're actually all
week but that was like beautiful
um
was there a lot of tourist back back
when you were living there ah
I did not see many in Osaka I did not
see many at all right I went the other
week and they were so goddamn well I've
heard now like post covered all of Japan
is just yeah yeah like yeah it's fine
crazy right now
um which makes sense like couldn't go
for so long and everybody I felt like
had this kind of like I want to travel
and I think Japan is it for everyone
yeah yeah myself included what was your
biggest uh culture shock when you got
there
like what was the one thing where you're
like whoa Japan is epic that's oh that's
a question it was the vending machines
honestly it was just how good the trains
were
oh my God our public transport is oh my
God yeah yeah [__] no like they they so
efficient yeah and I think I remember
once I was in there in the morning like
6 a.m and it was like everybody going to
work and it was like a stampede of like
workers oh yeah seriously it was
actually like dystopian yeah
like in unison they were walking almost
like like an army like just yeah through
these train stations like that was crazy
um that like that because that was my
first you know kind of experience with
trains and then like figuring out how it
works and once you work it out you're
like wow this is soul fishing it's so
great like color go here yeah literally
this color yeah no it makes sense
um I'm I'm curious because you know you
mentioned that your trip got cut short
uh and obviously you were only there for
two and a half months but you must have
moved there maybe when covered murmurs
were kind of already beginning yeah so
what was that kind of like that two
months of like monitoring lived there
the same time that we moved there
actually yeah that's we moved there like
three months before covered here
actually we moved we moved in October
and then covid lockdown officially kind
of started late April Yeah March April I
think I left February late February so
it must have been roughly the same time
yeah at the same time I traveled to
America in February of covid and that
was when they started asking like it
wasn't it wasn't everywhere yet there
was a few cases dotted around but they
were like oh have you been to China in
the past 14 days yeah you're like no no
why maybe like no reason
yeah no like I was definitely like every
day like I think everybody was right
like especially like being in Asia when
it you know originated in China it was
like yeah kind of like you know my
family were like well I I don't know
people didn't know anything yeah well
you didn't know everything and you've
seen all these articles and it's like
well I don't know how to believe this
guy that guy is a count on a sheet
somewhere going up every day like what's
the count today yeah I don't know it was
just kind of like I felt like I could
have got stuck there forever and maybe
like I think for you guys it sounded
like it was all right
worked out for us
if you'd have stayed you probably would
have been stuck there for the yeah 100
yeah a full year and like I didn't know
if I was Keen to do that
um because like I liked where I lived
but like I lost all the luxuries so I
different yeah no there's like because
it was Winter and I was in this like I'm
not kidding concrete Castle so like it
was cold as [__] so like he's gonna have
AC or heating it had heating but then
you get like super dry like so I tried
not to use it and I tried to have all
these like uh I'd use it in combination
with like an air uh or
umidifiers were stupid until I moved to
Japan yeah I've never had one before
yeah yeah seriously
um but yeah like I I I I missed my space
because yeah you don't get you don't you
don't get the space in Japan and I was
pretty Central to Osaka as well so like
I was really not getting a lot of space
yeah
um but yeah I was just like I don't know
if I could do this
right right eight ten months plus like
yeah it's I wasn't trying to be in a
pandemic in a country where I don't
speak the language like yeah yeah how
did you find like the uh nightlife there
because Osaka has a pretty like
Good Night Live scene yeah no uh we went
out pretty like no not too often but
like we definitely had like good
connections so like where my uh
girlfriend was working at the time she
had like connections with uh the the
some of the nightclubs running there and
so we'd go out and I actually became
really good friends with one of the
promoters at a couple of clubs oh wow
show us all these different clubs and no
it was a good time it was really good
time I'm gonna hit him up when I go back
yeah no
um yeah shout out my boy Mike
um but yeah no I I don't know do you
what did you guys like experience going
out like I know I've heard a couple bits
of you talking about like getting
rejected at certain places and stuff
some places don't want you yeah yeah
nothing like insane
um I mean we normally just go to bars
yeah we're not we're not big in a club
initially we when we moved there we
tried to go to like the local uh
izakayas and stuff like that and then
eventually we were just like I think I
think I just like bars now you know yeah
yeah I'm definitely in that bar scene
now like I just checked even if I have
to shout to talk to you it's not fun for
anyone yeah no it just like every time I
have to shout out samimasen like I feel
like as a Brit part of my lifespan just
like degrees you know because I know I
have to do it but every day I haven't
gotten used to it yet yeah so did you
get to try a lot of like new Japanese
foods like that like okay so there's
like the normal like mainstream kind of
like Ramen Sushi did you manage to try
like any other like Cuisines that aren't
as like popular so I tried one of those
like expensive Kobe beef experiences oh
yeah of course all right now where are
they so they overrated underrated where
are we doing okay is Kobe beef overrated
yes okay I can tell you that I I think
it is yeah I think it is it's great but
it's like it's kind of a one-off thing
because it's super fatty yeah yeah it's
really rich and really heavy it's like a
once or twice a year thing yeah yeah I
still prefer a normal steak like yeah
right normal steak for me is still
better than great wagyu beef beef is I
mean it doesn't even taste the same
mistake no it doesn't yeah no it's fat
yeah it's fat with a bit of meat in it
but like I had one of those ones where
it's like you sit down and they've got
them yeah yeah and they do that with the
Kobe and it was like okay this is kind
of a Vibe yeah I did that and Kobe
recently and it was I mean it was pretty
[__] good yeah you guys would have
done a few like sure because you guys do
like the Japanese travel video like yeah
type things like sure you've done a few
stints yeah I mean not even not even
just filming it just you know trying out
the experience because of course you you
have to you know
um and I remember when I did it uh they
they had like the option of just like
you know the amount of beef but you
could order an extra large portion as
well and I'm like yeah I'm getting like
the top tier beef man I gotta get the
extra large portion yeah and uh and I
remember having like half of it and that
half was like the perfect amount that
was like every bite was like Godly you
had to see the fat
um and then we got to the extra portion
and it just it was just too much yeah
like it started going from tasting like
Godly to like this is I actually feel
sick now yeah I had I made that mistake
when the first time I had the uh Olive
wagyu oh that's crazy it's more white
than pink yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's
like the first like two or three bites
was just like oh my God I'm about to not
and then and then the second half I'm
just like I'm just like drinking olive
oil it's just like I could feel my like
paws just clogging up this is where I
like Teppanyaki like a traditional
Teppanyaki is the best way to do it
because you'll have like a full course
meal of like uh other stuff like veg
fish yeah yeah all done on this thing
and then you'll have one course of like
all right we'll give you a little bit of
like maybe fatty beef or whatever like I
understand why the portions are so small
now yeah well that is the optimal amount
yeah the only problem is that it's like
[__] two to three hundred dollars
also yeah it is so expensive but if if
you you have a little bit of money
definitely recommend doing it yeah yeah
no it was something what did you think
of it no it was it was awesome but my
question to you guys have you guys done
the the the the puffer fish uh what's it
called yeah that is that that's
overrated okay no but like what's about
I've heard like a little sensation in
your mouth like oh obviously you can
blend when I had it yeah nothing it just
the problem is is that like because one
there's no flavor and two like unlike a
lot of other Sushi where you know it's
you can like chew it through it and it's
fine for some reason puff fish is like
it's really incredibly chewy so they
have to cut this thing like paper thin
yeah right because any thicker and
you'll just be it's like chewing gum
yeah wow that's not what you want and
it's like it's like prohibitively
expensive there's like a one in like 10
000 chance you can die from eating it as
well and I'm just like is it worth it
sounds like that's that just sounds it's
all just whatever you buy humans for
just hearing it's poisonous and just
being like we can find a way
we got it yeah what if we even get yeah
because surely people had to die
multiple times before they were like we
let's come on there must be something
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like we could
just stick to no we're doing this yeah
we've decided if I had to pick the most
overrated Japanese food it would
actually be puffer fish yeah because it
tastes like [__] it it's the only taste
you get is the taste of like the soy
sauce
um and you ate basically just eat it for
the danger you know maybe a
controversial opinion here I think Ramen
in Japan is but it's good but I also
think it's pretty good outside of Japan
now like I don't think it's necessarily
much better in Japan compared to like
some nice places you're getting some
good ramen Wales not whales yeah
I think I think if you pay enough money
yeah like the more like I guess like not
luxury but like inexpensive ramen places
outside of Japan I think have gotten to
the point where it's pretty difficult to
differentiate between like one made in
Japan one made outside okay but the
advantage that Japanese ramen has is
that is the price Factor yeah because
it's like for sure if you buy like a 10
Ramen in Japan nine times out of ten
it's pretty [__] good right if you
buy a 10 Ramen outside of Japan no that
was one time out of ten yeah yeah yeah
there's like a bunch like when I was in
uh Vancouver they have so many actual
just Japanese like uh like they're sorry
like a Japanese like uh Vancouver
counterpart to a Japanese restaurant
that exists yeah yeah so I had like
Hokkaido Ramen in Vancouver that tasted
just like it would in Japan well I think
it definitely much as well that like
yeah has such a high like Asian
population yeah yeah I think that's a
demand is I think that's less do with
Japan and more to do with just Vancouver
being like uh having an amazing yeah
culture yeah I I think that the point I
was gonna try and get at is that like I
don't think if you're coming to Japan
you only got like a week I don't think
you need to get Ramen I think there's a
lot of other stuff that you just cannot
get outside of Japan yes like unagi I've
never seen outside of Japan uh
yeah I had it yeah it's like smoked and
then grilled and coated with this really
nice like sauce yeah kind of like
barbecue kind of sauce yeah I had it I
was freaking out like [__] man I don't
want to eat it
was it was better than I thought it
would be oh yeah yeah I feel outside of
Japan eel just has this like weird thing
yeah I would like I'm not [__] eating
anything
I would not eat I think Japan eats like
half the world's eels or something crazy
yeah yeah I might have been I made that
the [__] up
say it's definitely the hottest it's
some it's like an insane amount that
Japan eats like a good chunk of the
world's percentage of eels yeah like
it's like almost impressive because
that's actually managed to make it good
yeah and they're 100 of the food the
British tried it and we were just like
let's just put in [__] jelly in it
yeah
that's so disgusting I still want to try
that oh no no you don't I just want to
see how bad it is it comes to [__]
pie
if you put your pie on the side like it
can't be good if it comes with a pie on
the side if I'd say one Japanese food
that I think you shouldn't need to try
if you come to Japan uh Japanese Curry
oh yeah I've had so many outside of
Japan yeah I I think Japanese Curry
tastes like the same everywhere I think
so and yeah it's pretty easy to
replicate yeah yeah it is like it's it's
one that is of like it's a nice comfort
food there is a place there's a place
where I'm like [__] yes give me some
Japanese Curry but holy [__] if I I've
said it I've said some outrageous things
about things tasting the same over my
years in trash taste but I do genuinely
think that Japanese Curry does taste the
same no matter where you are in the
world because it's so easy right yeah
like it's the simplest one to make like
it's like just you know just straight up
just the most standardized Curry that
you can get out of all the different
types of cards home blocks where you
just snap a block yeah yeah yeah yeah of
Curry and yeah you know Coco Ichi as
well especially is like almost
everywhere now at this point and it
really does just like taste the same
everywhere yeah the cauliflower rice is
pretty good cauliflower rice they do
like if you don't want the carbs you can
just get shredded cauliflower that's
right it's pretty good yeah yeah yeah I
don't feel as guilty yeah
have you guys seen the
um I've saw it on Tick Tock the other
week it was like these Frozen Ramen
packs you can get and apparently it's
meant to be like restaurant quality and
like that's what I'm saying I'm saying
if you go to Lawson's or anything yeah
and you have Ramen it's frozen yeah and
so that when you when you put it in the
microwave for like five minutes yeah
when you're heating up the oil again it
like dissolves and then boils again yeah
yeah and it is decent it's fine
Ramen but it's nowhere near
[Music]
yeah really I've never tried them I was
wondering if you guys have but yeah you
have I used to live off them for like
two weeks whatever yeah yeah kind of
like that's a weeb diet right there yeah
yeah it's funny because I kind of like
got off Ramen after I moved to Japan it
was super bad for you yes it's horrible
yeah yeah it's so much because I'd
realize after every time I'd have like a
big RAM and it would just like kind of
like knock me out for a few hours
because it's not one of those meals
where you can just have a nice Ramen
it's it's one and just like move on it's
just like after you have a Ramen you
just you need to just sit down for a
second I feel bloated yes digest yeah
you know you know yeah so I actually
like have not had much Ramen since I've
moved to Japan I've actually like sushi
I have sushi quite a lot though yeah so
Sushi has not gone down oh yeah of
course